tennessee tech was just caught hosting a  uh  a show it was a drag show  specifically for you know for all ages  mocking christianity take a listen  so you see the guy walks out dressed up  like a christian monk and these things  take me to church he mocks the crucifix  he makes the sign of the cross while  he's stripping this is all a reminder  that when you really get down to the  bottom of what politics is about it is  all about god i i use the quote on this  show very often from cardinal manning  that all politics all human conflict is  ultimately theological and we sometimes  forget that we hear people say actually  politics is about the battle between  liberty and equality you know what it is  it's a little more basic than all of  that  politics is a fight between good  and bad it's a battle for the soul of  the nation which side are you on